[Music]
oh
[Music]
my god kaylie cuoco just received her
first golden globe nomination
ever and the whole thing has her totally
emotional
i just love it now we're breaking down
more star reactions
snubs and surprises i've seen dateline
they zero in on one person that person
is me i'm going to jail you're not going
to jail yes i am you are definitely
going to jail
kaylee received her first ever numb for
best actress in a tv
series musical or comedy for her
performance in hbo max's the flight
attendant
i got to play so many different emotions
that i've never been able to do before
i've never had the opportunity so this
was my time
the 35 year old who serves as an
executive producer on the show
also received a nomination for best tv
series musical or
comedy and she shared the emotional
moment she learned the good news
on instagram oh my god
oh my god
she captioned the clip in part can't
stop crying
and in a statement obtained by e.t she
said in part
quote omg my heart is still pounding and
the tears
won't stop blowing it just feels really
good it's my first
nomination i'm gonna have some champagne
you know what this calls for some
champagne
amanda seyfried also received her first
golden globes nomination for her role as
actress marion davies in david fincher's
mank
make yourself to home mr menkowitz or
shall i call you herman please call me
man
she opened up to e.t about her
nomination shortly after she learned the
news
if this opportunity had come a little
earlier in my career i don't think i
would have been able to rise the
occasion
in this way i was really ready to embody
somebody else like this and
i didn't realize until it was it became
an opportunity
um that i couldn't resist but yeah i
think
i worked really hard it feels really
good to be
in the conversation and for to have a
spotlight on my performance
lily collins and her show emily in paris
pulled off the ultimate surprise
snagging two noms best actress in a tv
series
and best tv series musical or comedy
he won't let us into the atelier how do
i promote a show if i can't see the
clothes
the netflix comedy wasn't expected to
make a big splash of the globes and
lily couldn't be more excited about the
news in a statement obtained by e.t
she said in part quote i'm beyond
thrilled the series was recognized
and i feel so lucky to be in a category
including such incredible women
who have kept me laughing and smiling
all year long
and while lily might have surprised us
with her noms
no one was surprised to hear that shit's
creek got
five count em five nods
excuse me but the enchiladas were my
mother's recipe
i don't think so um it's not how i
remember it
after cleaning up at the emmys dan and
eugene levy said in a statement that
they are thrilled to celebrate the end
of the series with the show's first
golden globe nomination
you know we love it but it's the ladies
who made history on wednesday
nomad land director chloe zhao promising
young woman's emerald fennel
and one night in miami's regina king
became the sixth
seventh and eighth women ever to be
nominated for best director
marking the first time three women have
been up for the high honor
in the award show's history we're in the
regina king renaissance
i am here for it leslie odom jr received
noms for best actor in a supporting role
in a motion picture
and best original song for one night in
miami
my assistant did tell me he was like
listen there's a good chance
that we will be calling you very early
so please have your phone on so i said
i'll give you that i left my phone on so
so that i could be reached but i was
dead asleep what's going through my head
is that
um uh this is either really good news or
really bad news
but it wouldn't be an award show without
a few snubs
most notably zendaya wasn't recognized
in the best actress in a drama category
for her role in malcolm and marie
and meryl streep lost out on what would
have been a record-extending 33rd and
34th nomination
as she missed out on best actress in a
musical or comedy for both
let them all talk and the prom
we're not monsters
[Music]
we're cultural disruptors